they were like uh god made this video
about the fake timeline like oh some
things are wrong or oh how dare he get
you know make this video that's just
terrible and correct in so many ways i'm
like bro chill out man and i think some
of these were the smaller youtubers i
think they were getting like do you want
to make a video on it go ahead well i
think they have and they were just like
it's not as good as mine it's like
the point is you have to understand is
that you know if you're a fake youtuber
if you're a specific youtuber you're
going to be more focused on the oriented
details of it yeah when you're a more
general youtuber who covers more more
topics you know and you're covering a
wide span of things you're going to be
focusing on entertainment yeah right and
i feel god's video in a lot of ways was
more entertaining when i watch god i'm
not i'm not
you know i feel like i'm just defending
my friends
i'm feeling weird right now it's like
connor's defending me yeah
what's what's
you're missing the entire [ __ ] point
it's not to make a video that's correct
about faith it's a video that's
entertaining about faith the point is
that yes it's not going to be 100
correct if it is fantastic a great job
researching the point is is that yeah
that might annoy you that some details
are wrong and that you've put in all
this hard work and your video is not
going to get as many views but by by
making a video about fate uh you're
giving an avenue for more people to get
into fate yeah which you know when
someone big makes a video about
something that you do it's great because
you get a kick down effect whether you
like it or not you get that effect yeah
you know there's the fate uh people who
made videos about it are gonna get views
from that video because guess what's
going to be recommended on a fake video
yeah um and it was just very i don't
know it's just another case of people
just wanting to take shots at the big
guys and i don't know i've never really
had to deal with it so i
i'm all right but i feel bad for youtube
because for some reason you guys are
like punching bags for a little bit i
mean i don't know why i think it's weird
because
i i obviously never intended this but i
think it's just because we are seen as
kind of like pseudo critics or whatever
like i don't know like because i don't
see myself
as
anything of the sword i just see as
myself as like one guy giving an opinion
and i've and i've said that so many
times in videos but the moment you say
that to the reviewing a critic fan base
they're like oh he's just trying to be a
critic he's just trying to be a review
he's trying to take out jobs and i'm
like no i'm really not i just want to
make a video on this because i'm
passionate about it yeah yeah i mean
like i think there's there's two things
especially in the anime community
because the anime community grew up from
being like a very niche small community
right so sometimes like sometimes i will
make a video or i will title my video in
a certain way because i do it with the
assumption that
the person watching it knows nothing
about the topic i'm talking about and
the thing is because anime fans were and
still are especially in niche
communities very very dedicated to
whatever niche or whatever fandom that
they are a fan of they get i wouldn't
say very defensive but at least like
they are very judgmental about any kind
of content that gets made especially
like i mean we talked about faith but
like especially shown in community oh
yeah i don't know what it is about
shonen community that is
they are just so competitive with one
another
like because there's so many of them as
well yeah
and age like you say you say an opinion
you're like it's just basically
impossible to have an opinion on any any
singular shonen show right i'm not
it's it's it's especially difficult
especially like if you just make a tweet
or something or if you say i'm enjoying
x more than x well people people or
people will like take those words and be
like what the [ __ ] did he just say no
[ __ ] i remember i tweeted out ages
ago saying like you know what after
all these different manga that i've read
from like all the popular stuff to like
the niche stuff no one thinks about at
the end of the day i'm always going to
go back to shonen jump yeah and the
shonen jump like community got on my ass
for it be like i can't believe you're
discrediting shonen champion and shonen
sunday and i'm like i literally praised
you guys
what do you want what more do you want
me to say but the thing the thing i've
noticed right is that this is for some
reason it's it's
for the most part only
only contained in like the shonen
community and the shonen culture yeah
like for example i listen i'm the isikai
guy right yeah so let's say guys i
prefer re zero over no game no life
nobody better
no nobody back tonight yeah i say i
prefer demon slay over uh i say i prefer
demon slayer
[ __ ] sake i say i prefer demon slay
over
demon slayer demon
slayer controversial opinion
i say i prefer my hero academia to
jiu-jitsu tyson everyone loses their
mind i don't by the way
that was just that was just a that was
just a random quote that i just
generated that that's gonna turn the
internet on fire but of course someone's
gonna take that out of context and be
like i can't believe god said that yeah
i think there's nobody who respects my
opinion so
it's kind of no that's what i want i
don't i don't want people
but i want that at this point like like
i get it that you know
because i have never really criticized
shows i just kind of say i like it or i
don't i've never really gone and i think
it's when you've criticized church
people get there people start to
probably in some aspects value your
opinion
which you know i respect them
yeah i respect in a lot of ways but at
the same time it's like there are some
people there's a difference between
respecting and understanding an opinion
and taking that into consideration and
also basing your entire life around that
person's opinions yeah you know like i
even me like i've tried to
talking about
anime content i've tried to not be so
negative or like i've tried to like only
focus on things that i do like and i
that i want to highlight right because
that's a big difference
[Music]
no because i didn't used to be that way
i used to be like you know i used to
like clown on a lot of shows but now now
i at least try to
try to
just talk about things i like but even
even if i just make a quick joke about
something that then that one line from a
video that had nothing to do with
that topic or that fandom that that you
know that
one quote gets spread around on twitter
and spread around everywhere and
especially now that we stream and we're
on trash tasty
there are people that can just take one
line out of context from a conversation
that's not even to do with the anime i'm
talking about and just be like oh god
thinks this or god thinks that and i've
i i guess it's just something i've had
to learn to deal with as
my contact
same things as you
i could say the exact same things as you
and nobody will bat an eye but the
moment you say it it's like bro shit's
going down it's like c don't be a
certain opinion it's pretty strange yeah
it's like
an opinion yeah i should almost be
offended that nobody gives a [ __ ] what i
say but on the other hand i'm like great
if it means i don't have to deal with
this [ __ ]
god i wish i was you
well i think i think part of it just
comes with time as well because
unfortunately the longer you are on the
platform or the internet them the more
quote unquote like i hate calling them
haters because that just that just like
people who dislike you the more the more
people who dislike you will slowly build
up because i remember i i remember when
i first started my youtube channel and
like
i think like the first five years of
contents most of the
opinions i saw of me were mostly
positive right but then there would be
one comments that you know had a
negative opinion of me or like one small
community and the longer you're on
youtube the more like the more
negativity that gets built up slowly
over time just because one your audience
is getting bigger and two a lot of times
when you get a hater or when you get
something someone who doesn't like your
content they're just gonna stay that way
and they're just not gonna give you the
chance or another opportunity yeah
because they're not gonna watch your
content anymore so that one opinion they
have you is going to remain that way
throughout the rest of your youtube
career right so i think it's also a
thing with time as well because i think
a lot of big youtubers who've been on
this platform for a long time have had
to deal with
negativity building up over time and i
think i think there's no one that
epitomizes this more than maybe felix
and i like i've never personally talked
to the guy but from what you've
said about
what he said to you and about how he
deals with it it's just like it just
seems like the most mature way it's just
it's just something you just got to deal
with right yeah honestly it just comes a
part of the job